hey friends and welcome back to rapid
fire language learning today we're
exploring the question how to read books
in a foreign language
reading a book in a foreign language is
tough because in order to read
comfortably you need to know a lot of
words so
language learning is a marathon and you
need to take it step by step
first read one page a day
for a long period of time and
progressively increase the number of
pages you read
and second make sure that you choose
short interesting books that you have
already read in your
native language so that you know the
content it's easier to deal with and you
know that you're not going to get bored
because you already know the content you
have
chosen yourself the book this is what i
did for
this specific book which is called
atomic habits i got it i read it in
english and then i got it myself
in polish if you want to know more about
language learning in general
please check out my channel there's
hundreds of videos about language
learning in general
and happy language learning and over and
out